Football Leaks, filtre du Football Leaks, Title Football Leaks, Footballer Leaks, Website, die schnüffelt Football Leaks, ein Website, die schnüffelt, ein Thema und jede Menge Nachspielzeit. Heute sprechen wir im Rasenfunk über ein Thema, das um die Welt ging, nämlich die Football Leaks, ein euch sicherlich nicht ganz neues Thema, denn es hat auch schon im Rasenfunk stattgefunden, es gibt dazu schon einen Kurzpass und ein Tribünengespräch und nun aus aktuellem Anlass ein zweites Tribünengespräch. Und ich freue mich, dass wiederum Rafael Buschmann, einer der Autoren der Football Leaks und derjenige, der diesen Datenschatz in Händen hält oder hielt zumindest als Erster, wieder die Zeit sich genommen hat, um mit mir darüber zu sprechen. Hallo Rafael.
Ich freue mich selber, die Einladung.
Ja, da kommt mir aber gleich wieder in den Sinn, dass du vorhin noch gesagt hast, dass du gerade mein Computer an- und ausschalten kannst. Das ist ja ein hochtechnologisches Thema und wenn ich dann zum Beispiel das jetzt ein bisschen Nerd-Talk entschuldigt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, aber vor ein paar Tagen, nicht allzu lange her, wurde bekannt, dass manche PGP-Verschlüsselungen inzwischen auch nicht mehr sicher verschlüsselt sind. Nicht alle generell, aber das heißt, man muss ja auch immer auf dem Laufenden bleiben, was quasi den aktuellen State-of-the-Art-Verschlüsselungsmechanismen im Digitalen betrifft und kann sich dann dennoch sehr sicher sein, dass diejenigen, die versuchen, sowas zu knacken, immer einen Vorsprung haben. Denn wir erfahren ja auch nur einen ganz kleinen Teil davon. Und ich kenne zum Beispiel auch einen Journalisten, der sehr viel im Bereich der Geheimdienste recherchiert, was der mir für Geschichten erzählt, was der tun muss, um seine digitalen Spuren zu verwischen. Das ist dann für mich schon sehr komplex und ich würde mich als jemanden bezeichnen, der eher technologieaffin ist. Wie kannst du das denn leisten?
Ja, also das ist in Wahrheit auch eine gewisse Steuerung, die dann der Whistleblower vornimmt, indem mir der Whistleblower oder John sagt, über welche Kanäle er mit mir sprechen möchte und diese Kanäle mir dann an die Hand gibt. Mir dann sagt, wo ich mich einloggen kann, wie ich mich einloggen kann, was ich mir runterladen muss. Dem folge ich dann und versuche, diese von ihm gewählten Kanäle dann auch zu nutzen. Es ist in der Regel so, dass er selten einen verschlüsselten Chat über einen längeren Zeitraum benutzt. Er benutzt auch keine PGPs. Als ich ihm das erste Mal gesagt habe, dass ich ihn gerne PGP schreiben möchte, hat er mich lauthaft ausgelacht, weil er einfach gesagt hat, das ist okay, wenn wir das machen, können wir uns auch direkt Postkarten zuschicken. Das hat er mir vor zweieinhalb Jahren schon gesagt. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Es gibt Kanäle, die für mich, wenn ich ehrlich bin, eine völlig neue Welt waren und auch ein bisschen mich erschrocken haben, weil ich mit so etwas vorher noch nie gearbeitet habe. Ich möchte jetzt die Namen der einzelnen Chat-Räume natürlich nicht benennen, aber es gibt Chat-Räume, in denen ich beispielsweise eine Nachricht schicke und innerhalb von 15 Sekunden, nachdem der Satz aufgetaucht ist in diesem Chat-Bereich, wird der Satz auch wieder gelöscht, also von alleine. Das heißt, in dem Moment kann man das Handy nicht weglegen, sondern er schreibt mir dann über Chat A, dass wir uns jetzt in Chat D treffen. Dann gehe ich in diesen Chat D und dort schreiben wir dann quasi im Live-Modus. Ich schreibe ihm meine Nachricht, liest er und sie wird in diesen 15 Sekunden gelöscht. Er schreibt mir zurück, seine Nachricht wird gelöscht, ich schreibe meine Nachricht, die wird gelöscht. So dass es im Prinzip auch keine oder es schwer ist für jemanden A in der Geschwindigkeit dort reinzukommen und B dann auch mitlesen zu können. Das ist fast alles, was wir nutzen, ist auch mit einem dreifachen oder. Vierfachen Passwortschlüssel im Vorfeld gesichert. Das ist eine Art Zufallsgenerator, der in Verbindung mit einem Passwort oder mit einem weiteren digitalen Fingerabdruck die Möglichkeit gibt, bestimmte Räume betreten zu können. Und so sichern wir unsere Kommunikation ab. Das ist in Wahrheit – ich hab das ja auch im Buch mal ausformuliert – ich wünsche jedem Geheimdienst viel Spaß dabei, der das lesen möchte, weil es teilweise ja auch nicht nur um die dreckigen Geschäfte im Fußball geht, sondern wir dann auch gemeinsam ein Spiel sezieren und wir uns über die Taktik dieses Spiels unterhalten und er mir seinen Eindruck gibt, warum Real Madrid gerade Bayern München besiegt und womit das zusammenhinkt. Und ich ihm dann erkläre, wo ich die Schwächen von Bayern München gesehen habe oder die Stärken von Real Madrid. Wenn das ein Geheimdienst mitliest, dann wird er nach kürzester Zeit, glaube ich, auch die Krise kriegen, weil dann auch schon viel blödsinnige Quatsche auch mit dabei natürlich ist, wie ganz normale Fußballzuschauer sich eben dann auch das ein oder andere Mal über ein Spiel unterhalten.
Ich glaube, dass man da zwar sehr viel lernen könnte, aber ja, ich verstehe da.
Genau, also er ist auch soweit, das muss ich echt sagen, er ist soweit Fußball fit, dass er auch taktische Elemente sehen kann, dass er über Fußball als solche sehr, sehr detailliert und tief reden kann. Ich habe das jetzt so ein bisschen spöttisch und abwertend gesagt, aber das, was er unterschreibt, ist teilweise auch schon sehr spannend. Das macht Spaß, aber es gibt kein Erkenntnisgewinn für einen Geheimdienst, wenn er da mitlesen möchte. Deshalb haben wir auch unterschiedliche Sicherheitsstufen, bei den Chats, die wir nutzen. Diese Sicherheitsstufen sind in erster Linie damit oder hängen damit zusammen, welche Passwortelemente man im Vorfeld eingibt. Für den einen oder anderen Chatraum brauche ich auch 20 Minuten, bevor ich da überhaupt drin bin.
Das ist fast, als würden wir über Skype zu Football Leaks telefonieren.
Das sind in Wahrheit Chaträume, die auch unsere IT oftmals gar nicht kennen, die ich im Vorfeld nicht gekannt habe, die aber John kennt. Ich bewege mich damit auch in einem Raum rein, in dem ich anfange, mich mit solchen Dingen zu beschäftigen und feststelle, wie bestimmte Whistleblower sich zu schützen in der Lage sind oder über was sie sprechen wollen. Das ist ein spannendes Feld, auch wenn ich wie gesagt technisch davon einfach keine Ahnung habe, aber zumindest in der Endbenutzung gelingt es mir ab und an.
Ja, aber auch jetzt wird es dann ein journalistisches Thema, deswegen stelle ich nur kurze These in den Raum. Aber Whistleblower müssen inzwischen auch ein Grundwissen an digitalen Verschleierungstaktiken mitbringen. Es reicht eben heutzutage nicht mehr, eine Steuersünde-CD irgendwo hinzuschicken oder einer Zeitung in einem Tiefgarage irgendetwas zuzuflüstern, sondern heutzutage bedeutet Whistleblower sein auch, dass man digital sehr, sehr weit vorne mit dabei sein muss, in einem Bereich, den man wahrscheinlich schlecht ergoogeln kann, denn sonst würden sie ja alle tun, vermute ich einfach mal. Absolut.
Um das nur mal kurz einzureißen, die Digitalisierung ist oftmals ein Segen für den normalen Alltagsgebrauch. Für die investigative Arbeit ist sie aber die Hölle eigentlich. Weil sehr, sehr viele Quellen entweder mittlerweile komplett darauf verzichten, sich digital auszutauschen. Dann wird eben ganz simpel von einer toten SIM-Karte einmal auf ein Festnetz angerufen. Und zwar auf ein Festnetz, das im Vorfeld als genau das bezeichnet wurde, eben als Sorgenstation, auf die man dann an einem Tag in der Woche anruft und dann beide sich im Vorfeld bei ihrem persönlichen Termin darauf verständigt haben. Und dann werden Termine ausgemacht, persönliche Termine. Ich habe Ermittler und Fahnder, die, wenn ich mich mit denen treffe, das ist mittlerweile schon echt hochgradige Paranoia. Da darf kein Handy mit, da darf kein Computer mit. Ich kann noch nicht einmal mit meinem eigenen Auto im Vorfeld anfahren, die tun es auch nicht. Und dann trifft man sich an Orten, die tatsächlich sehr, sehr blickgeschützt sind und ich mir dann manchmal auch frage, wo ich eigentlich, in welcher Welt ich eigentlich lebe, weil mir das dann auch schon so ein bisschen zu sehr nach Kino und zu sehr nach James-Borne-Filmen vorkommt.
Im Umgang mit heiklen Quellen ist es sehr gut, wenn man manchmal auch Namen vergisst.
Vor allem, wenn man dann hinterher befragt wird.
Ja, genau, wenn dich dann irgendwelche Leute in langen Podcasts grillen. Aber du schaffst es ja sehr gut, alles zu um Schiffen. Wir haben noch ein paar Fragen und zwar zum Teil auch, sehr konkrete Fragen. Da geht es noch einmal bei der einen um die Hintergründe der – ja, das Wisseblower John und vielleicht einer Agenda. Und zwar hat Zerstreuung Fußball zwei Zitate mitgebracht aus dem Buch und dazu konkrete Fragen gestellt. Das eine ist ein Zitat, es sind jetzt beides Mails, die von John stammen sollen oder zumindest von ihm gesagt wurden. Das eine Zitat ist, unser Antrieb ist es, all denen das Handwerk zu legen, die sich zu Unrecht an dem Volkssport Fußball bereichern. Und das zweite Zitat zahlt darauf ein, das lautet, diese Leute kontrollieren den europäischen Fußball und machen dabei unentwegt miteinander Geschäfte unter dem Tisch. Spieler und Vereine werden durch sie zu Marionetten. Wir haben Dokumente, die das belegen. Wenn du sie liest, wirst du dir die Frage stellen, wie man überhaupt noch an diesen Sport glauben kann. Und er äußert sich jetzt dahingehend dazu, dass er sagt, dass diese Sätze recht unkommentiert stehen gelassen wurden, deswegen will er dich dazu eben noch mal befragen. Und er findet vor allem das zweite Zitat, wo es eben dann um diese Leute, die den europäischen Fußball kontrollieren, geht, ein bisschen problematisch. Denn er fragt ja, welche Dokumente sind damit gemeint und gibt es tatsächlich eine kleine Gruppe von Menschen, die den komplettischen europäischen Fußball kontrolliert? Oder wie war das vermutlich gemeint von John?
Schwierige Frage, weil ich sie so auch nicht beantworten kann. Das hängt so ein bisschen auch mit dem whistleblower zusammen. Manche dieser Formulierung lässt er auch so stehen. Ich habe sehr bewusst versucht, im Buch mich nah an der Person zu halten und auch wenn man wenig über ihn sagen kann, zumindest die Charakteristiken dieses Menschen wiederzugeben. Auch auf Nachfrage, wer denn genau damit gemeint ist, wird er selten konkreter. Er sagt dann, guck dir die Berater an, ich zeige dir hier die Dokumente. Und dann gibt es eben Dokumente, die Jorge Mendes zum Beispiel betreffen, bei denen ich bis dahin ja immer gedacht habe, er ist ein normaler Spielerberater und wir dann mit den Dokumenten feststellen, ist er nicht. Er hat Fonds, über die mit anderen gemeinsam in Vereine investiert wird. Er verkauft Anteile seiner Firma an chinesische Investoren, um dann gemeinsam in Fußballvereine wieder zu investieren oder zu reinvestieren. Er unterhält sehr, sehr enge Geschäftsbeziehungen zu Präsidenten von Vereinen, wie zum Beispiel Lim von Valencia, der lustigerweise dann auch noch die Bildrechte von Cristiano Ronaldo ankauft. Das muss man sich vorstellen, der Präsident des FC Valencia kauft die Bildrechte eines Fußballers, eines direkten Konkurrenten von Real Madrid. Das ganze läuft natürlich auch mit Gestaltung von Jorge Mendes. Dann zeigt mir John Documento von Mino Raiola, der an einem Transfer von Paul Pogba 49 Millionen verdient, weil er eben sowohl Bioventus Turin als auch Manchester United als auch mit Paul Pogba zusammenarbeitet. Daran sieht man, dass John uns versucht, natürlich in die groben Machenschaften von der ein oder anderen Person Einblicke zu verschaffen, aber das ich bislang noch nicht gesehen habe, was er mit einer Agenda meint. Ich habe immer von ihm verstanden, dass er, egal in welches Segment des Fußballs er reingeschaut hat, festgestellt hat, dass dort irgendetwas nicht mit rechten Dingen zuging und dass er immer wieder auch formuliert und sagt, der Fußball ist eine so enorme Blase. Im Fußball selbst kommen immer wieder die gleichen Player zugeltend, immer wieder die gleichen Personen haben miteinander zu tun und dieses Business lebt von den Personen, die seit Jahrzehnten eigentlich in einem Vertrauensverhältnis zueinander stehen. Und wenn diese Personen dauerhaft voneinander profitieren, sind sie ja auch nicht in der Lage, nach außen irgendjemanden zu belasten, weil du belastest niemanden, von dem du so massiv profitierst und vielleicht beim nächsten Transfer wieder profitierst oder bei der nächsten Beteiligung an irgendeinem Verein profitierst. John hat immer wieder gesagt, durch diese Intransparenz und durch den Einfluss von Superagenten – und damit meinte er immer Leute wie Mendez, wie Rayola, wie Simonian, auch Sahavi, all diese echten Großmeister – durch diesen Einfluss passiert es auch, dass teilweise die Spieler zwischen den Vereinen wie Marionetten hin und her geschoben werden. Wenn Mino Rayola in einem Transferfenster Mikitarian, Pokba und Ibrahimovic bei Manchester United unterbringen kann, dann ist dieser Berater ein enormer Einfluss auf einen der absoluten Spitzenvereine in Europa. Das gleiche gilt für Mendez, der das sehr gezielt mit bestimmten Vereinen macht. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt meine Interpretation dessen, worum es John in diesen Zitaten geht, weil er, seitdem ich mit ihm zu tun habe, immer wieder genau diese Sachen erzählt und wiedergibt. Aber ansonsten ist es nicht so, dass er ein so stringenter Mensch ist, der seine Zitate, die ihm zwischendurch auch mal einfallen, großartig erklärt. Sondern er sagt sie und dann lässt er sie auch mal im Raum stehen, auch wenn eine Nachfrage kommt, lässt er sie im Raum stehen und denkt dann weiter darüber nach, was er als nächstes sagt oder wo wir als nächstes hingehen oder was wir als nächstes essen. Da sind Menschen eben auch unterschiedlich und ich versuche, seine Eigenheiten zu akzeptieren, weil ich eben dann auch nur alle paar Wochen mit ihm zu tun habe. Wenn er jetzt ein direkter Arbeitskollege wäre, würde ich wahrscheinlich dann auch schon irgendwann mal sagen, nimm mal zu, das musst du mir näher erklären oder darüber müssen wir detaillierter sprechen. Das kann man mit einem Whistleblower in der Form nicht machen, wenn er selbst – das ist ein sehr verschwiegender Mensch, das muss man dazusagen – dass er, der schafft es auch oft, egal in welchem Aggregatzustand er sich gerade befindet, eben dann auch auf Sachen nicht zu antworten, wenn man sich das wünscht. Wenn man diese Antwort gerade haben möchte und John sie aber nicht haben oder sie nicht geben möchte, dann tut er das auch nicht.
Ja, irgendwie ja auch alles ganz gut erklärbar. Und wenn wir schon bei dieser Frage nach wenigen großen Superagenten und Marionetten und so weiter im Geschäft sind, dann kann ich da auch noch eine Frage anschließen, die Marc Wiese gestellt hat, der dich auch mal für den Sportjournalist interviewt hat. Er lässt dich herzlich grüßen an dieser Stelle.
Vielen Dank, schöne Grüße zurück.
Ihn würde interessieren, ob und wenn ja mit welchen Vereinen Dorian Sports derzeit in Anführungszeichen kooperiert. Gibt es noch Geschäftsmodelle, die ähnlich sind zu dem damaligen mit Wente Enskede? Also bereichert sich Dorian weiter an klammen Clubs?
Dazu muss ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, weil Dorian nach wie vor eine Geschichte für uns ist und ich so sehr ich euren Podcasts schätze, Spiegelgeschichten auch im Podcast nicht vorgreifen kann, aber darauf hinweisen kann, dass wir Dorian Sports nach wie vor im Auge haben und nach wie vor über sie schreiben wollen und weiterschreiben wollen. Es ist so, dass die Firma sich aktuell völlig neu strukturiert, dass sie ihren Geschäftsitz gerade verlagert hat, erneut in eine Steueroase nach Dubai, dass sie immer noch in dem Geschäft tätig ist, aber dass sie ihr Geschäftsfeld ein bisschen verändert hat. So viel kann ich, glaube ich, jetzt hier schon verraten und alles andere werde ich zu gegebener Zeit dann auch mal posten.
Sehr gut, Herr Cliffhanger. Ich glaube, es hat das Näschen von Mark Wiese bewiesen. Er hat da auf die richtige Stelle gezeigt und du hättest ja auch einfach nur antworten können mit Ja, aber du hast jetzt ein etwas längeres und umständlicheres Ja gemacht und den Rest müssen wir dann einfach abwarten.
Ja, das Problem natürlich auch an der Form des Podcasts – und ich hoffe, dass das die Leser verstehen – ist, dass ich versuche, so viel Transparenz wie möglich in meine Arbeit reinzubekommen, aber natürliche Grenzen in dieser Transparenz habe. Ich kann nicht über alles sprechen, weil ich eben sowohl die Quelle schützen muss, als auch die Interessen meines Hauses schützen muss und zwar über Geschichten, die nicht geschrieben und nicht konfrontiert sind, natürlich im Vorfeld auch nicht sprechen darf oder sprechen kann. Bevor ich etwas über eine Firma, über die Zukunft einer Firma sage, muss ich natürlich auch als seriöser Journalist dieser Firma die Möglichkeit geben, ein Statement dazu abzugeben. Und wenn ich das dann habe, bin ich gerne in der Situation, darüber bei euch auch im Podcast zu sprechen.
Das werden wir sicherlich auch noch häufiger tun. Zuletzt würde ich gerne noch einen anderen Aspekt beleuchten, den eben die Hörerinnen und Hörer aufgeworfen haben. Es ist ja so ein bisschen eure Sendung. Wir haben jetzt schon darüber gesprochen, was die Justiz gemacht hat nach den Veröffentlichungen der Football Leaks. Wir haben schon ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, welche Dinge sich verändert haben für den Whistleblower und auch für dich. Und jetzt gab es auch noch einige Fragen logischerweise zur möglichen Reaktion der Verbände und des Fußballs an sich. Und da hat unter anderem Piszczdy geschrieben, warum ist es eigentlich nicht so, dass zum Beispiel DFL die DFL in ihren Lizenzierungsunterlagen nicht nur so Dinge festsetzt, wie ein Stadion muss überdacht sein und über 10.000 Sitze haben und Parkplatzgrößen, sondern auch Corporate Governance Forderungen und Transparenzansprüche da reinschreibt. Er nennt da einige Beispiele, die sehr, die eben, wenn man sich mit diesem Bereich auseinandersetzt, man aus anderen Branchen eben kennt, dass alle Personen in Organfunktionen, juristische Personen unter Vorstrafen sind, dass es Kontrollmechanismen gibt, dass die Lizenz verweigert werden kann, wenn bestimmte Transparenzansprüchen nicht Rechnung getragen wird. Er geht da sehr ins Detail. Aber was hältst du denn davon? Was könnte er denn oder was müsste denn der Fußball tun, um jetzt darauf zu reagieren, was ihr da alles jetzt aufdecken konntet und könnt?
Das ist das Naheliegende aus all den dunklen Geschäften, die wir jetzt auch beschreiben, dass man genau diese Sachen implementiert, dass man eben nicht irgendeine Ethikkommission gründet, die mit ehemaligen Politikern besetzt wird, die mittlerweile aus dem Geschäft raus sind, um ein Feigenblatt zu haben oder Aufsichtsräte zu gründen, wo ausschließlich Freunde und Förderer des Vereins drin sitzen, sondern dass es sehr, sehr verbindliche Compliance und New-Diligence-Formulierungen, Regularien im Fußball gibt, dass selbstverständlich eine Transparenz bei Verbänden in viel, viel höherer Form von den jeweiligen Vereinen eingefordert werden muss. Dass es beispielsweise so etwas geben muss wie Clearing Houses eigentlich. Das ist eine Forderung, die eigentlich von John kommt, der ich mich aber inhaltlich schon auch anschließen kann, weil ich glaube, dass sie dem Fußball extrem weiterhelfen würde, wenn man nicht eben nur wie die DFL jedes Jahr vermeldet, dass die Ausgaben für Spielerberater sich wieder um 50 Prozent oder 100 Prozent gesteigert haben, sondern dass man eben auch Handwerkszeug oder Werkzeug entwickelt, um herauszufinden, wo diese Gelder hingehen, wer sie eigentlich erhalten hat, wie die Geldflüsse der jeweiligen Vereine diesbezüglich ausgesehen haben. Und zwar nicht nur bis zum ersten Stroman, sondern bis zu allen Firmen, die an einem solchen Deal beteiligt sind. Ja, selbstverständlich wären das genau die Konsequenzen, die eigentlich ein Verband oder die Verbände daraus ziehen müssten. Wir sehen aber oder stellen fest, dass es viel einfacher ist im Fußball, solange auch kein Druck von Justiz und Politik da ist, eben genau das andere zu sagen. Und zu sagen, wir machen jetzt hier zwei, drei kleinere Feigenblätter und werden ansonsten schon irgendwie da durchkommen, weil morgen das nächste Spiel ist und das nächste schöne Tor ist. Und am Ende, dass natürlich dann auch jegliche Form von Kritik so ein bisschen erdrückt. Daran hängen sich ja Verbände auch intensiv auf. Wir haben nach den Football Leaks mal mit Gianni Infantino ein langes Interview geführt, bei dem er lang und breit uns erklärt hat, dass er sich das alles angucken wird.
Das war legendär, legendär. Was er alles nicht wusste, das hatte fast schon Niersbach Dimensionen.
Ja, total, total. Das war wie ein Reh auf einer Eisplatte, von links nach rechts gerutscht, keine klare Aussage. Seitdem ist bei der FIFA ja diesbezüglich nichts passiert. Es ist immer noch ein totales Eldorado für Spielerberater, sich in diesem Business zu bewegen, weil es immer noch keine echten Regularien gibt. Die FIFA hat einfach da die weiße Fahne gehisst vor einigen Jahren und hat gesagt, die Spielerberater werden jetzt von den Nationalverbänden reglementiert oder reguliert. Die Nationalverbände sagen, wie zur Hölle sollen wir das tun, wenn das natürlich ein globales Business ist. Wir können dann nur das abbilden, was hier in Deutschland passiert. Wenn es da nicht ernsthafte Bemühungen gibt und zwar sowohl vom Weltverband als auch vom Europäischen Verband, dem ein bisschen mehr entgegenzusetzen als nur zu sagen, wir werden uns das angucken, dann wird sich da auch selbstverständlich nichts ändern, bis irgendwann mal die Justiz eingreift und ebenso ähnlich wie es damals bei der FIFA war, es zu großen Razzien, zu großen Hausdurchsuchungen kommt und das Ganze auf den Kopf gestellt wird. Wir sehen jetzt schon, welche groben Sorgen und auch Vorsichtsmaßnahmen, beispielsweise in Spanien oder Portugal, auch in Teilen in Frankreich in Bezug auf die Versteuerung von Bildrechten vorgenommen werden und wie sensibilisiert mittlerweile Verbände und Vereine diesbezüglich sind, weil sie durch unsere Berichterstattung enorm aufgeschreckt wurden. Ich lege da auch beide Hände für ins Feuer, dass in den nächsten Monaten noch deutlich mehr an Ermittlungsverfahren da auch auf die jeweiligen Vereine und Spieler zukommen wird. Von solchen Dingen würde man eigentlich von einer solchen Multimilliardenbranche erwarten, dass sie sie auch schon versucht zu lösen, bevor das Problem tatsächlich öffentlich wird, also dass sie versucht damit umzugehen, bevor der große Knall da ist. Aber der Fußball – und das sehen wir auch an ganz vielen der Veröffentlichungen der letzten Jahre – reagiert erst, wenn ihm irgendwas auf die Füße gefallen ist. Und oftmals reagiert er dann auch nur so, dass dann die handelnden Köpfe quasi weggeschnitten werden und einfach aus dem jeweiligen Fleisch neues Fleisch nachwächst. Ja genau, das ist das ist etwas, was in der Regel dazu führt, dass solche Branchen irgendwann mal dann auch kollabieren, weil es unmöglich ist, auf Dauer ein solches Business so aufrecht zu erhalten. Wir sehen es ja jetzt schon, dass es einen Zuschauerschwund gibt, dass die Stadien nicht mehr ausverkauft sind, dass an der einen oder anderen Stelle eben das Interesse auch zurückgeht. Und das hängt mit ganz vielen dieser Entwicklungen zusammen, die nicht nur Football Leaks sind, sondern die generell den Einfluss des Geldes und auch der Profitgier im Fußball widerspiegeln. Ich bin aber, ich selbst sehe aber für uns keine großen weiteren Möglichkeiten, den Verbänden zu erklären, wie sie das lösen könnten, außer so, wie wir es machen. Und zwar indem wir Woche für Woche, Monat für Monat Enthüllungen dazu machen und ihnen zeigen, was alles nicht gut läuft.
Aber hältst du es denn realistisch, dass aus den Verbänden heraus sich da etwas tun wird? Denn die FIFA ist ja ein perfektes Beispiel. Dann kommen Korruptionsvorwürfe raus. Im Grunde kannst du so, wie man früher die ersten zehn der Tour de France dann im Jahr danach alle durchstreichen konnte, weil Doping rauskam, so kannst du bei der FIFA irgendwann im Exekutivkomitee, kannst du jetzt auch den Rutsch ansetzen und sagen, okay, ist inzwischen Korruption nachgewiesen, ist angeklagt, ist nachgewiesen, ist angeklagt. Und was passiert? Die Köpfe werden ausgetauscht, es gibt einen neuen Kopf, der Hydra und das Spiel geht weiter. Ich vermute mal, du hast einen engeren und tieferen Einblick in die FIFA und auch in die UEFA als ich. Gibt es denn da überhaupt Kräfte, in die man als Fußballfan Hoffnung setzen kann, dass sich da der Verband irgendwann selbst reguliert oder ist das komplett hoffnungslos und es müsste wenn dann über politischen oder finanziellen Druck geschehen von außen?
Ich persönlich glaube nicht, dass der Fußball in der Lage ist, sich selbst noch zu retten. Ich glaube, dass das nur funktionieren kann, wenn Politik und Justiz sich dessen viel stärker vornehmen. Und selbst dann wird es sehr, sehr lange dauern, um eine Form von Säuberung in diesem Business, in dieser Branche herzustellen. Ich glaube in der Tat, dass der Fußball das auch gar nicht möchte. Warum auch? Das ist ein Produkt, das extrem viel Geld abwirft, das extrem gut für die Leute in der Branche funktioniert. Warum sollten sie sich jetzt an der Stelle damit beschäftigen, was in zehn Jahren der Fall ist, oder was in fünf Jahren der Fall ist? Wenn ihnen ein paar Zuschauer weggehen, dann gibt es auf der Welt noch weitere Märkte, wo man Zuschauer akquirieren kann oder wo man Zuschauer finden kann. Dann geht man halt nach Asien oder nach Amerika. Die Welt ist groß und die Globalisierung funktioniert an vielen Stellen. Also ich glaube, dass es dort dieses Bedürfnis nicht gibt. Es muss von Seiten der Politik ein Aufwachen stattfinden, dass man mit dem Fußball nicht nur als Politiker glänzen kann, sondern dass es durchaus notwendig ist, dem Fußball auch genau auf die Finger zu schauen und zu sagen, brauchen wir nicht bestimmte Regularien, um die Geldflüsse, diese immensen Geldflüsse besser zu steuern. Das ist ein Vergleich möglicherweise zu der Weltwirtschaftskrise 2009. Nach der Weltwirtschaftskrise sind rund um die Banken ein deutlich schärferes Geldwäschegesetz verhängt worden. Es sind Due-Diligence- und Compliance-Regeln aufgenommen worden. Sie funktionieren auch nicht hundertprozentig, aber sie haben vieles verändert und besser gemacht. Auch das Bankengeheimnis ist an vielen Stellen zerbröselt, was ein sehr wichtiger Faktor war, um die Transparenz in absurde Geldflüsse hinein zu bekommen. Ich glaube, dass der Fußball über kurz oder lang vor einer ähnlichen Umwälzung stehen wird, weil ich persönlich auch immer wieder die Frage aufwerfe, warum all die arabischen, russischen, chinesischen Investoren seit dieser Weltwirtschaftskrise und seit den extremen Beschränkungen in Bezug auf Geldwäsche auf einmal den Fußball für sich erkannt haben und auf einmal festgestellt haben, dass es dort extreme Anreize gibt, um Gelder einsetzen zu können. Das sind Menschen, bei denen man nicht immer sagen kann, dass das ausgewiesene Fußballfans sind, die aber auf diese Art und Weise natürlich ein Vehikel für sich auch finden können. Das tun nicht alle, sondern der eine oder andere von denen, die ein Vehikel finden können, um natürlich ihre Gelder dann von A nach B zu bekommen mit einem Transfer oder mit einem Sponsoring oder mit einem Honorar an einen Berater, bei dem es vielleicht über das normale Bankenwesen deutlich schwieriger geworden wäre.
Ja, ich glaube, das Thema wird uns noch lange beschäftigen. Rafael, vielen, vielen Dank dir. Das Buch Football Leaks ist in der aktualisierten Taschenbuchausgabe erschienen in der Verlagsgruppe Random House, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und es gibt jetzt auch eine englischsprachige Variante davon für diejenigen von euch, die gerne die internationale Version lesen würden. Rafael, vielen, vielen Dank, dass du dir mal wieder Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk.
Liebe Grüße an die Zuhörerschaft. Ich hoffe, ich konnte das ein oder andere erklären und würde mich freuen, wenn wir so verbleiben könnten.
Ja, das können wir sehr gerne so machen, dass du wiederkommst, sobald es etwas Neues gibt. Man kann dir auch auf Twitter folgen, etrafanelli, und ich bin sicher, du wirst auch dort auf die ein oder andere Nachfrage nochmal gerne eingehen, wenn jetzt dem einen oder anderen oder der eine oder anderen hier noch was gefehlt hat. Rafael, danke dir. Vielen Dank euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, sowohl für die Unterstützung als auch für die ganzen Fragen. Das war eure Sendung heute. Es hat großen Spaß, mir gemacht, eure Fragen zu stellen. Bis bald, macht es gut, ciao. Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.